cannes est un véritable le cri d'alarmé
pour dénoncer le manque de personnel de
spécialistes et d'appareils ultra
performantes de radiographie le
gouvernement l'an passé avait pourtant
annoncé 11 millions de francs pour la
création de postes mais les hôpitaux
n'ont rien vu venir et à la détresse de
ces patients qui ont déjà surmonté à
combattre la maladie
s'ajoute au quotidien les conséquences
de service débordé parfois mal équipés
laurence chare fait jean marc sur ça
avec une vingtaine de lits le service de
cancérologie de l'hôpital saint louis ne
peut recevoir plus de malades
tous les jours il faut donc annulé les
rendez-vous une contrainte pour les
médecins un supplice pour les patients
liliane est atteinte d'un cancer du sein
en face de chimiothérapie ces
rendez-vous ont plusieurs fois été
reportée on est prêtes à sac est prêt et
on est tous concentrés on sait qu'on va
y aller c'est fait sinécure de crécy et
puis raconter son pouvoir avoir ce genre
de lombez et c'est vraiment la mauvaise
nouvelle quand même ça va déstabiliser
je vous dis mais c'est pas possible
c'est comme début de match sérieuse
comment se fait-il qu'il va classe pour
recevoir tout le monde douze mille
consultations par an dans le service six
mois d'attentes pour certains malades
impossible pour ce spécialiste du cancer
du sein de voir de nouvelles patientes
des conséquences directement lié au
manque de cancérologues pourquoi les
internautes choisissent plus à
cancérologie parce qu'il ya pas plus
cher l'hôpital puisque à part poste donc
c'est un cercle vicieux dont une faute
de poste faute de moyens actuellement la
demande et il n'y a pas de d'étudiants
qui se forme dans cette discipline
les postes de psychologues consacré aux
malades sont rares à saint louis il n'y
a même pas un poste à plein temps que
indépendante des hôpitaux l'agent ce
cancer de la ville de paris tente de
combler ce vide créé il ya neuf mois
elle propose des rendez vous gratuit
avec l'assistante sociale et psychologue
une nécessité pour les malades il a
besoin avant tout qu'on informe qu'ils
comprennent ce qui lui arrive au plan
médical mais aussi au plan administratif
au plan psychologique au plan social au
plan professionnel
cette information elle n'est donnée
nulle part elle n'est pas structurée
n'existe pas l'initiative insuffisante
aux yeux des médecins
sept cent mille malades sont
actuellement soignés en france contre le
cancer